so the Samsung Galaxy fold definitely
wasn't the first foldable phone we've
ever seen we've seen so many different
foldable phones from so many different
companies like Oppo Motorola Huawei LG
and even the brand-new ones that we're
getting to see now from Xiaomi but why
is everybody so obsessed with the
Samsung Galaxy fold and all this new
affordable tech that we're looking at
today what's going on guys my name is
David Tommy and welcome back to the
channel today we're talking about the
samsung galaxy fold and the future of
technology in the foldable smartphone
department I don't know about you guys
but I'm super excited to see where
foldable phones are gonna take us and
what kind of leaps and bounds we can
make in foldable tech in the next five
years so back talking about the Samsung
Galaxy fold over the past couple of
months we've seen some incredible things
unfold and really come into place with
this foldable phone when a few limited
and lucky test reviewers got their hands
on it we saw a lot of different things
go wrong with the device we saw people
try a peel the screen all of a sudden
that the screen started cracking and
dead pixels arrived everywhere dust and
dirt was getting under the screen
countless and I mean countless examples
of these images were popping up on
Twitter on social media all around the
world of different reviewers having
different problems with this phone so
obviously Samsung being one of the
biggest companies in the world that
manufactures smart phones and a whole
array of other devices they had to make
an executive decision here and create a
full product recall and stop production
on the Samsung Galaxy fold that all
occurred about five months ago and only
last week we started getting some real
information back from Samsung about the
future of the Samsung Galaxy forward and
what we can expect as consumers so
Samsung is completely re-engineered the
Samsung Galaxy fold to make it a lot
more durable and a lot more suited to
the average consumer especially ones
that aren't robots in the lab constantly
folding and closing the phone countless
times people have already started
putting the Samsung Galaxy fold through
its paces by getting their hands
on the original Korean version that's
available to the public now people in
Australia won't actually be seeing the
Samsung Galaxy following anytime soon
Samsung hasn't come out with an official
statement saying they will be launching
the Samsung Galaxy fold at all basically
in Australia they have said that it will
be coming to the US market very shortly
within about a week or two people in the
US will be able to buy it personally I
don't think that the Samsung Galaxy fold
will actually sell too well after all
these little debacles and all these
problems people are actually going to be
a little bit wary of going out and
purchasing your Samsung Galaxy fold
especially with that premium 3000 plus
Australian dollar price tag I don't know
about you guys but I wouldn't be going
out and spending 3 grand on a phone that
is extremely delicate and comes with a
giant list of warnings of what you can
and can't do with it before you even
turn it on for the first time now here's
my two cents on the topic basically
everybody's coming out and saying that
they can't really see the purpose of any
foldable phones or any foldable tech for
the current market and the reason why
I'm focusing on Samson over any other of
these foldable phones is because Samsung
is a giant world-renowned company that
can spend millions if not billions of
dollars on R&D to get a product perfect
for the market so if we think about
Samsung as a company as a whole they're
already producing some incredible
smartphones the new Samsung Note 10 is
so powerful is basically a mini tablet
and a mini laptop all-in-one and you
don't really need anything else to get
you through your day now if you're able
to implement the power of the Samsung
Note 10 into something like the fold and
the versatility of the s-pen then
potentially this could become your daily
driver you might even be able to replace
your laptop when you need to with a
product like this take it one step
further with Samsung Samsung has already
released their Dex program which allows
you to connect your device to a little
docking station and all of a sudden
you're basically running a laptop on an
external monitor so if you think about
this like an entrepreneur or somebody
that's willing to do business on a
multinational scale well Sam
is basically positioning themselves to
be able to create a phone that is going
to outweigh every single other device on
the market and they're gonna be able to
kill it when it comes to sales just
imagine having your phone being I would
unfold once into a brand new tablet just
as powerful as your laptop and then when
you do need it say you've just come to
work you pop it on that dock and all of
a sudden you have your brand-new desktop
up and running taking it in the day go
home continue your work and basically
you have your full versatility your full
productivity in the tiny package of a
smart phone now something that's
actually spiked my interest is the
xiaomi folding phone that folds in on
itself and actually has two folds on the
one screen now our fan is particularly
interesting because this means that
folding screens could actually be folded
multiple times over so imagine having
your smartphone that can fold once like
the samsung fold does and it produces
your tablet size device and then all of
a sudden you need it to be a bit more
powerful and you need a bit bigger
screen size and you can fold it out
again over itself and then all of a
sudden you have a laptop sized screen
that's able to work as a full laptop as
well if we were even to push the
boundaries even further imagine being
able to unfold it again to the fourth
time and create something like a desktop
monitor behind you that you can
literally place in front of you anywhere
around the world and has a full 21 27
inch screen ready to go at your disposal
wherever you need it and all of your
data and all your protesting power to do
any job you need personally I think that
the folding phone market is something
that is definitely not ready yet for the
average consumer and it is more of a
prototype concept to say yes we can do
something like this and yes we are going
to keep researching and developing to
really try and make sure this product is
ready for the market in the future in
ways we can't even
now these products definitely aren't
going to be folding like origami if
that's what you have in your mind right
now but they will more than likely start
to fold and create very useful devices
that are pretty much gonna integrate
themselves into our daily life without
it even knowing it so yes the prices are
getting astronomical but at the same
time we are spending two three thousand
dollars on a laptop to three thousand
dollars on a phone and then all of a
sudden to three thousand dollars on a
camera as well I think personally these
tech giants are trying to incorporate
everything into the one device for us to
be able to really condense everything
and maximize the technology inside the
product so that's just my two cents on
the Samsung Galaxy fold guys and the
future of the technology of foldable
phones and folded with devices I really
hope you enjoyed the video if you did
make sure you smash that subscribe
button
20:19 style and as always I'll see you
next Monday